is this just like a normal cheese plate
yeah it seems like it
yeah you get that flaky cheese what's on
it I don't want to eat any dairy I don't
want to pump up the mucus you don't eat
dairy no I just don't want to pump up
the mucus man that cheese is excellent I
gotta say yeah it looks good really
really good how about the drink oh that
[__] looks good okay we can get started
on the drinks
but we have a lot of time so I was kind
of trying to Pace myself but
first drink we got oh you can guess it
uh come and then try it I'm guessing on
ooh is that Jizzy soda yeah yeah this is
[__] shot soda
ranch dressing soda I was gonna say that
looks like dishwasher fluid this is
horrendous
that looks like dishwasher fluid to the
fullest is it I guess we'll find out
Lester's fixing
Lester's Fixins Lester you're a sick
[__]
you shouldn't eat anything
[Laughter]
dude that is so [__] bad
yeah I bring that over here just in case
for the future ones
holy hell
all right all right
I'm gonna take a guess now
yeah
[Laughter]
thanks gang preach you just have some
crackers man
cheers
I'm not hungry anymore that's
you're gonna guess the other flavors
it's like horrendous will you taste them
I will for sure taste some I'll do that
after okay
hot sauce
piss
barbecue sauce
why would you make that
I just don't understand I would love to
see someone chugging down on that in
public
yeah just like not like mad casual yeah
just like just like walking somewhere
and you like do a double take you're
walking by them and you're like
just chilling at them dudes sitting at
the bus stop in [__] 95 degrees
that is like gag inducing
this so did they do a good job with the
getting it accurate then
yeah they did they nailed it
Lester
you're a genius sorry Lester Cody's out
on wrench so you have to guess them
before you okay this one is and then you
drink it and then check what it is oh
okay I like that
this one is hot Cheeto I think that'd be
good that's a good one yeah I couldn't
think of anything Orange
okay it smells like orange
hmm
that's really good what's in it buffalo
wing soda oh it doesn't taste like that
at all I guess this was hot sauce I'm
not about to drink it I just want to
know if I'm right
oh gross what is it pumpkin pie no it
sounds awesome
oh pie is a drink dude I bet she's good
although it's like
you know it's almost spring
pumpkins are a little out of season it's
not really the time you know that's why
it might be gross because of that
oh in March yeah
it like starts like pumpkin and then
it's like chemicals
yeah it kind of nails it that one's for
sure piss yeah it has yeah it has to be
busy it's got to be pissed let me taste
it first let me take it first
no okay what code are you doing let me
taste it
I think it's just a Corona
it's just Beer soda
Beer soda for kids yeah
what does it smell like wait give me a
little whiff
give me a lift
that's not too bad that caught me off
guard
that was it was like I think you got a
good waft if you pop the top and the
smoke came out I was like
corn syrups
the bottle of corn syrup oh it's a
thickest soda I've ever
[Laughter]
good good guys man I feel like [__]
my mouth tastes like nickels
my left arm is numb
why do I smell copper
go ahead dude
all right Lester cheers
it does it does yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
there's there's nothing wrong it's corn
yeah it's corn yeah like just straight
up corn yeah there's nothing wrong with
that flavor you just shouldn't drink
shouldn't be able to drink it you know
what that is you know what that is they
took a can of corn and and then they
drained all like yeah they drained all
the juice out of it holy [__] dude
[Laughter]
are you not entertained that [__] better
just say corn if it tries to if it tries
to say it's anything else it doesn't
even say sod on it yeah yeah if you're
trying to say it's anything else I'll
throw that bottle through the window
right now don't even [__] lie
sweet corn oh dude sweet corn soda
oh my God
[Laughter]
so bad it's bad dude so bad the whiff
alone
the gesturing that she's after you just
domed it off I have another smell no I'm
good
[Laughter]
dude I feel like you just drank from a
canola oil bottle yeah just the [__]
remnants
you're best at canola oil all right
root beer tasting from Deer ass
this is a deer's ass how was the hot
sauce one the hot sauce one it was fine
Cody wants to try it I think
yeah well after that one
my um
last three idiot oh
wow what the [__]
a real man
bacon bacon
yeah that's [__] epic excuse me me
lady
allow me to take an epic sweat of this
baking soda oh tip of the hat to you my
sir literally bacon literally bacon
ew bro oh bro
that's nasty dude that's so yeah
you look like with dogs
[Laughter]
that's the funniest genre of video to me
is dogs like gagging like yeah hacking
up it's so good remember that one yeah
[Laughter]
he's hacking up a hairball
that's horrendous oh bro that literally
literally it actually tastes like they
collect the like runoff cooking bacon
and make soda out of it that tastes
as if you lick the pan after you cook 50
strips of bacon yeah it's gonna be a
horrible day
[Laughter]
after this whole day is shot
so thanks